i'm kind of curious with you canelo who
were some of the mexican fighters
growing up that you felt that you
admired because i remember growing up
we're somewhat similar age i remember
barretta morales
trilogy i used that for my brother my
older brother
but and then uh eddie
showed me a lot of videos of gilberto
roman julio chavez
um
not too much
yeah i'm curious to know where did you
get your left hook to the body and then
you go like fake the lap hook to the
upper did you did you find that in your
did you take that from somebody that you
that inspired you with that left hook to
the body and then coming up top in the
gym
i i learned in the gym with eddie and he
have
a lot of experience
he he loves to learn every day so i find
sometimes
by myself to
do things but i learn from it from eddie
did you know crystal ball christopher
used to work with um
yeah he said he said he he liked the
resistance that salvador brought but he
said technically there's a little more
mexican legends that that he looked up
to and that he studied
i loved um
i think um sanchez is just hard to beat
he's one of those guys
that um this would make him so special
with sanchez this has made him really
special
to me and everybody else that knows his
style
if you if you're a halfway fighter
decent fighter you might
last distance as good as you are you're
greater you are the more he kicks your
ass
he fights right above the level of the
game that he's fighting
you will ass kill he's gonna [ __ ] you up
he's just he's just above everybody else
yeah and last time he was just such a
bad [ __ ] you're talking about
salvador yeah yeah he died yeah he was
that bad [ __ ] yeah he beat the
zoom in never zooming out of the animal
he beat it oh man
well we'll freddie gomez
[Applause]
um
yeah i'm and i think about that i'm
thinking about all the like the
trilogies like you know the barrera
morales you've always had either mexican
spiders or mexicans fighting against
puerto rico
[Music]
you